find the sum 3 and 1 8 plus 3 4 plus
negative 2 and 1 6. let's just do the
first part first it's pretty
straightforward we have two positive
numbers let me draw a number line
so let me draw a number line and i'll
try to focus in so we're going to start
at 3 and 1 8. so let's break this 0. so
you have 1
and then you have 4
3 and 1 8 is going to be right about
there so let me just draw its absolute
value so this
3 and 1 8
3 and 1 8 is going to be
3 and 1 8 to the right of zero so it's
going to be exactly that distance
from zero to the right so this right
here the length of this arrow you could
view it as three and one eighths
now whenever i like to deal with
fractions especially when they have
different denominators and and all of
that i like to deal with them as
improper fractions it makes the addition
and the subtraction and actually the
multiplication the division a lot easier
so 3 and 1 8 is the same thing as 8
times 3 is 24
plus 1 is 25 over 8. so this is 25 over
8 which is the same thing as 3 and 1 8.
another way to think about it 3 is 24
over 8 and you add 1 8 to that so you
get 25 over 8. so this is our starting
point
now to that we're going to add
three-fourths
we are going to add three fourths so
we're going to move another three
fourths we are going to move another
three fourths
it's hard drawing these arrows we're
going to move another three fourths
to the right so this right here the
length of this that we're moving to the
right is 3 4. so plus 3 4. now where
does this put us well both of these are
positive integers so we can just add
them we just have to find a like
denominator so we have 25 over 8.
we have 25
over eight
plus three fourths that's the same thing
as we need to find a common denominator
here the common denominator or the least
common multiple of four and eight is
eight it's going to be something over
eight to get from four to eight we
multiply by two so we have to multiply
three by two as well so you get six so
three fourths is the same thing as six
eight six eighths if we have 25 eighths
and we're adding 6 8 to that that gives
us 25 plus 6 is 31
over 8. so this number right over here
this number right over here
is 31
over 8
31 over 8. and it makes sense because 32
over 8 would be 4 so it should be a
little bit less than 4. so this number
right over here
this number right over here
is 31 over 8 or the length of this arrow
the absolute value of that number is 31
over 8.
a little bit less than a little bit less
than four if you wanted to write that as
a mixed number it would be it would be
what three and seven it would be three
and seven eighths so that's that right
over here this is 31 31 over eight
that's that part right over there now to
that we want to add
a negative 2 and 1 6. so we're going to
add a negative number so think about
what negative 2 and 1 6 is going to be
like so let me do this in a new color
do it in pink negative 2 and 1 6. so
we're going to subtract or i guess we
say we're going to add a negative 1
we're going to add a negative 2 and then
a negative 1 6. let me draw so negative
2 and 1 6 we could literally draw like
this
we could literally draw it like this
negative 2 and 1 6 we can draw with an
arrow that looks something like that
so this is negative 2 and 1 6. now
there's a couple of ways to think about
it you could just say hey look
when you add this arrow this thing
that's moving to the left right we could
put it over here and you would get
straight to negative 2 and 1 6. but
we're adding this negative 2 and 1 6.
it's the same thing as as subtracting a
positive 2 and 1 6. we're moving 2 and 1
6 to the left and we're going to end up
we're going to end up with a number
whose absolute value is going to look
something like that and it's actually
going to be to the right so it's not
going to only be its absolute value it's
going to be well its absolute value is
going to be the number since it's going
to be a positive number so let's just
think about what it is this value right
here which is going to be the answer to
our problem is just going to be the
difference of 31 over 8 and 2 and 1 6.
and it's the positive difference because
we're dealing with a positive number so
we just take 31 over 8 and from that we
will subtract 2 and 1 6.
so let's do this so this orange value is
going to be 31 over 8
31 over 8 minus 2 and 1 6.
so 2 and 1 6 is the same thing as 6
times 2 is 12 plus 1 is 13.
plus minus 13 over 6 and this is equal
to once again we need to get a common
denominator over here and looks like 24
will be the common denominator
and let me make it very clear
this 31 this is the 31 over 8 and this
is the 2 and 1 6. this right here is the
2 and 1 6. so 31 over 8 over 24 you have
to multiply by 3 to get to the 24 over
here so we multiply by 3 on the 31 that
gives us 93
and then to go from six to 24 you have
to multiply by four let me do that in
another color
you have to multiply it by four
so we have to multiply by four up here
as well
so four times thirteen let's see 4 times
10 is 40.
4 times 3 is 12 so that's 52.
so this is going to be equal to
93 minus 52 over 24 and that is so 93
minus 52 3 minus 2 is 1 9 minus 5 is 4
so it is 41 over
41 over 24 positive and you can see that
here just by looking at the number line
this right here is 41
over
24 and it should be a little bit less
than 2 because 2 would be 48 over 24. so
this would be 48 over 24 and it makes
sense that we're a little bit less than
that